اذا الاغنيه بتهدد شعب كامل معناته لازم
كلنا نعرف شو اهميه الكلمه والاغنيه في
مواجهه هذا المحتل
نقش الفن الفلسطيني منذ النكبه فعلا
مقاوما وكب كافه مراحل النضال لم تقتصر
السرديه الفنيه الفلسطينيه على الغناء بل
تجاوزتها الى غالبيه الفنون الاخرى وقد
تنوعت الفنون التشكيليه الفلسطينيه التي
اشتبكت مع الاحتلال وصولا الى فنون الشارع
التي جعلت جدرانها معرضا للفنانين
والمقاومين من بدايات الانتفاضه الاولى
بلش اللي هو فن الشارع فهو كان عباره عن
طريقه لتوصيل رساله المقاوم
للمشاهد او للمحتل على الرغم من قله
الافلام الفلسطينيه طوال تاريخها الحديث
نجحت مجموعه من الافلام بحصد جوائز عالميه
متجاوزه كافه العراقيل التي تلاحق الاعمال
الفلسطينيه مثل فيلم
[موسيقى]
واعتقلتهم الجمارك او وقفتهم لحديت معنا
ادفع مبالغ هائله انا لا املكها اصلا على
الاحتلال
صحيح احتلال الاسرائيلي
مضايقه الفنانين والمره كمان
المضايقات عمليا
فكره الكوفيه هي فكره لغه تفاهم بيننا
وبين الشعب السويدي ما كنت امسك العود
واغني يجي ميه ويسقفولي ومبسوطين طب انا
لقيت انه بقدر افهم الناس قضيتي
لم يكن النشاط الفلسطيني الفني خارج
فلسطين بمعزل عن المضايقات اذ كانت تهمه
معاداه الساميه حاضره دائما لتقييد كافه
الانشطه الثقافيه الفلسطينيه حول العالم
لانه بيخافوا من الاعلام وهذا اللي بيقتل
اسرائيل هن عايشين على الاعلام
حافظه الفنون الفلسطينيه مع تتابع الاجيال
على مهمتها الواضحه في الابقاء على فلسطين
نتحدى وذاكرتها وتراثها ونضالها
موضوعا ومنهجا ومشروعا فنيا مؤثرا تخاطب
فيه الداخل وتصدره للخارج رغم كل العوائق
ومضايقات الاحتلال
[موسيقى]